good morning believe nation today's
episode of believe life is going to
focus on how you can improve your
relationships the line date I was 22
just 22 he was just 23 I thought I got a
hold on to this marriage she proposed we
talked about it and we got engaged
we've been married for 50 years and both
or should imagine secure in the marriage
not afraid of losing the other one but
at this stage of our lives do you worry
about losing your mate by yourself
that's it it's a hard thing you get so
used to somebody be merriment and in one
day one of us is not gonna be there you
messed up just
sometimes thinking of that the upside
glove bracelets at the downside it's
still worth it
you
you
how to be great in a relationship begins
with having the intention to be great I
know that sounds so simple but you meet
so many people who who they jump into a
relationship that is so excited to find
their girlfriend their boyfriend to get
married to have that husband to that
wife that partner and they're so excited
about it and then over a period of time
when it's been happening they get caught
in a routine they get to know the person
better they develop you know habits and
responses and pet peeves and all of a
sudden they stop seeing the magic and
the very person they met with and
intentionally had this idea to grow this
great relationship you know we're gonna
be amazing together and people stop
putting great intention and great
efforts into their relationships and
over a period of time they feel ho-hum
and they start to die and you and I both
know that so the challenge is this if
you want to have a great relationship
your intention must be to be great to
make the other person feel great and to
build a great life together
if you need to place restrictions on
people in your life something is wrong
for example if you're a girl and you
need to tell your boyfriend hey you
can't go to that party because that
certain girl is gonna be there and I
don't trust that situation that should
be a huge red flag like straight up red
flag so huge
using China there is no way you can
justify that you have to place
restrictions on your partner for them to
remain loyal to you because here's a
question why would you want to be in
that situation why would you want to be
with someone that you can't trust in the
first place because why don't you want
to be with someone who goes to the party
looks damn fine at the party has a blast
at the party
remains loyal at the party and then
comes back home to you after the party
and I'm sorry to be so blunt but you
know I like to keep it real all right
you can place any amount of restrictions
on someone but if they want to cheat on
you they're going to cheat on you well
goal is not to place restrictions around
the person so they don't the goal is to
be with someone that won't you have to
adore people if you don't adore the
person that you are with right now you
have to Risa man that up
you have to look for the things in them
that will help you do that and the way
to do that give them more attention show
them more appreciation when they receive
more attention and more appreciation
from you there there be an energetic
change in the relationship it will turn
more vibrant more they'll be more pop in
it and all of a sudden you'll start to
notice that person they come a little
more alive around you and it'll be
easier to adore them because you're like
oh look I never even noticed they do
these things that's funny or all gosh I
never noticed they did all these things
for me I have attention to that now and
I appreciate that now you'll start to
adore them more when you adore the
person with you with more you do things
for them you do more things for them you
want to see them light up you start
supporting their dreams more how are you
doing that because real adoration is
getting out of your own way and asking
what is it about this person's life that
I can support that they love to do
because showing real adoration is
showing support real adoration is not
just doting on somebody with flowers and
gifts though you should do that too it's
about wanting to support their bigger
life goals their bigger dreams when you
truly adore somebody you want so
desperately to see them happy and
passionate engage living their own fully
charged life when you really adore
someone you go out of your way out of
your way to brag about them in front of
them right when they're there and you're
in a social situation you compliment
them you'll you'll brag about them and
you make them like if you haven't made
your partner your spouse your lover your
husband your wife blush for a while with
a good compliment in front of other
people what are you doing right I'm
always trying to embarrass my poor lady
you know and in a positive way because
I'll compliment her in front of other
people and [ __ ] like I really appreciate
you said that about me because I want
her to feel adored I want everybody in
the community I want everybody in my
life know how much I adore my lady so do
you have that intention for yours for
the person who's you're with does
everybody know how much you adore them
are you bragging them up
are you really adoring them personally
and publicly when you do that you'll
notice a different level of engagement
in that relationship too and everything
will change because they will feel
adored appreciated and feel like you're
giving them attention so they'll turn it
around now though they give you more
attention
more appreciation more endorsing or an
addition and there'll be this spark and
it happens between the two of you that
you never imagined that you could have
that is what it feels like to live the
charged life I feel like too many people
rely on other people for happiness
encouragement and motivation oh you're
upset well I guess that means someone
has to cheer you up
oh you're slacking well I guess someone
needs to tell you to work harder you
accomplished something or someone better
pat you on the back this is not cute and
okay hold out don't get me wrong of
course sometimes it is nice to rely on
someone else I mean everyone is human I
mean when I'm sick yeah I want someone
to make me soup sometimes it's nice to
depend on someone sometimes but if you
constantly need someone to make you feel
good then you really need to stop and
ask yourself why can't you make yourself
feel good one of the things that we
found is we meet couples and very often
people say you guys seem like you know
you're newlyweds or they'll ask us did
you guys just get married what you're
really proud of up to 12 years but it's
not a matter of time that makes that
difference if you're single one of the
reasons that people find themself in a
relationship that they're unhappy with
is they're filtering today's
relationship through the past and one of
the things that we've done for anybody
we're gonna help is get you to clear the
decks of the pass and step into who you
with right here and right now that can
start to create a difference because in
the beginning of a relationship what do
you look what were you willing to do for
that person anything anything
whatever it takes now after a few months
or a few weeks or a few years all of a
sudden you're saying you know would you
take out the trash in the beginning
you're like whatever you want the trash
I'm happy to do it for you now it's like
you know what I look like your janitor
so learning how to be able to create
that aliveness again and not filter your
partner through an old story is one of
the most important things you can do to
have a passionate relationship I also
think that if you think about it the
very beginning of the relationship the
very things you're most attracted to
very often when the relationship goes
bad you reject the things that you loved
you know in the beginning you may have
been very you know enticed by this
person because they seemed very
mysterious and quiet and now you're
pissed off that they're quiet all this
time or the beginning you thought well I
love them cuz they had so much energy
and passion they just took over the room
and how do you like why is it
to talk all the damn time you know do
they ever shut up one of the things that
happens in relationships is if we don't
realize that what we're attracted to and
the other person that we think is so
different than us is just another part
of ourselves that we're not actively
utilizing and if you don't use your
partner to trigger that awakening inside
yourself eventually you resent them
because you resent that part of yourself
as being shut down I think you both have
you know certainly we would respect
there's little crazy pieces that drive
each other crazy but to shift those to
actually appreciations and one of the
gifts we certainly give each other is
rather than having that irritation to
actually be humored and to be playful
about it so it just breaks the pattern
and creates you know just brings an
aliveness and a playfulness to the
relationship you like the fact that my
wife needs to have your nine hours of
sleep and only needs actually four and I
beg him to go to bed at night after 12
years that's still something that
transpires and others daily life every
relationship me begging for some food
anyway here's our point if you want to
have an extraordinary relationship it
really requires you to get outside of
yourself we all know that when you
really fall in love with somebody it is
really about what can I do for you first
what are you doing for me the end of a
relationship is when you're evaluating
what they have done versus what you've
done if you've got a scorecard you're on
your way out and that doesn't mean it
can't be turned around you know the
happy of relationship can be eliminated
when you step into that mode of giving
and interestingly enough when people are
attracted to each other though you don't
have these problems because when people
have that sense of attraction that
energy that sensuality that sexuality
what happens is you have filters you
laugh about things you'd be upset about
before so all the research that we found
and all in our own lives and the
literally the hundreds of thousands
couples we work with because we can tell
you all these things are talking about
but ultimately you need more passion
because lots of couples actually have
love but they don't have that level of
passion they want and there's an
emptiness there's a a missing energy in
their life and so for us the secret is
really to unleash that again thank you
so much for watching I made this video
because Ramesh asked me to so if there's
another topic that you want me to cover
in the next edition of believed life
leave in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do
I'd love to know which of the advice
resonated the most with you you're going
to take some action on and what are you
gonna do to now try to go out and
improve your relationship leave in the
comments below I would personally love
to hear and I think it might also
inspire others to take action as well
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon